Copywriting is going to be huge. Let me
tell you why. Because there's two paths
being created right now in the AI age.
There's a path that 99% of people are
going to go down. They're going to use
AI to prompt and write all of their
copy. And then there's going to be a
much smaller, much narrower path of
people like me who are going to study
and master the fundamentals. And
eventually, those paths will collide
again once the people who are prompting
and using AI start getting copy that
doesn't convert and they don't know why.
Because they don't understand the
fundamentals. It's the same thing as if
I were trying to code something. I don't
know anything about code, but I can use
AI to code something for me. And
eventually, I'm going to run into errors
and things that don't work, but I don't
know how to fix it because I don't know
code. This is going to create a massive
desire for people who actually do
understand copy and know how to make
something convert. Which tells me